[Musique]
c'est maintenant l'heure de votre
chronique dédiée aux plus jeunes
aujourd'hui michael almy doro est en
plateau avec nous pour nous parler du
syli petit déj de montigny le bretonneux
bonjour michael pour camille alors
effectivement je vais vous parler de
l'un des rendez vous les plus prisés à
montigny-le-bretonneux le ciné petit déj
qui se tiendra ce dimanche 16 octobre à
la salle jacques brel je vous vois
sourire camille ce n'est pas une blague
dès que les billets sont mis en vente
les familles se jettent dessus les 250
places de jacques brel sont facilement
prise
ils trouvent facilement preneurs
l'adjoint au maire délégué à la vie
culturelle à montier motors jose cachin
nous donne les objectifs de ce rendez
vous c'est de donner la possibilité aux
familles l'hymne antenne de se retrouver
un dimanche matin autour d'un moment
très convivial des familles qui en
général ont des enfants qui sont en bas
âge
donc ça leur permet de se retrouver
autour d'un petit déjeuner avec des
maquillages qui sont prévues pour les
enfants et puis autour d'une projection
de film qui s'adresse aux plus petits ce
n'est pas une nouveauté mutuelle
puisqu'il ya déjà eu deux éditions voilà
on ne change pas une recette qui
fonctionne les deux dernières éditions
toutes les deux heures programmées cette
année on fait le plein comme je le
disais précédemment
l'idée de créer un ciné à petit déj tous
les trimestres à destination des 5 à 8
ans présentation du concept on a un
atelier maquillage qui est prévue en bas
où les enfants peuvent se maquille et on
a un grand buffet avec un petit déjeuner
les parents viennent se servir les
enfants viennent se servir ça se passe
sur scène voilà
jusqu'au moment où on invite les gens à
s'asseoir avant la projection du film
donc on est sur un créneau qui est de 10
heures 12 heures
alors nous parler du concept depuis tout
à l'heure mais ce qu'on aimerait savoir
aussi c'est quel film sera projeté
dimanche j'y arrive qui a mis un petit
peu de patience les familles pourront
voir le film d'animation annie la sortie
en 2013 ce dessin animé a été réalisée
par l'uruguayen alfredo soder git
il raconte l'histoire d'une petite fille
à reus se voyant puni après une bagarre
on regarde un extrait
je m'appelle ali nayad taille ça lasse
mon nom est un palindrome il peut se
lire dans les deux sens à l'endroit
comme à l'envers
amine ouadahi seul à ce que des
palindromes au nom 6-3 palindrome on
dirait une blague mais alors ça ne te
plaît pas
dans mon école il ya des camarades que
j'adore et d'autres qui m'a ce film
n'est pas très connu du grand public et
c'est l'objectif comme nous l'expliquent
josek achats on écoute on est on est
toujours à la recherche de projection
qui sortent des projections qu'on peut
trouver dans les grandes salles de
cinéma l'objectif c'est pas de diffuser
dessin animé pixar ou autre c'est
justement de sensibiliser les plus
jeunes un une catégorie de cinéma qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de voir donc on est
toujours dans une recherche de deux
films qui sont les films un message
thématiques ou autres voilà celui ci
l'ont fait partie c'est terminé pour
cette chronique j'ai oublié de vous
donner le prix pour assister à ce ciné
petit déj il faudra débourser 3 euros 90
à par personne si vous êtes intéressé ne
tardait pas il reste quelques places
vous pouvez le retirer à l'hôtel de
ville ou directement sur le site le jour
j vous allez acheter quelques billets
peut-être camille je sais pas par anton
votre famille où vous allez et matous
salon pour moi tout seul là ne me
sous-estimer mickael j'aime beaucoup les
films d'animations en tous cas merci
beaucoup nous a reparlé de ce ciné petit
déj on vous le rappelle c'est ce
dimanche à 10 heures à la salle jacques
brel on